[Música]
Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo del
programa de France 24 en el que los
periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos de manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los temas
destacados de la semana para conversar
sobre la selección de temas de esta
semana hemos invitado a Inés cap devila
ella es periodista secretaria de la
redacción del diario La Nación en
Argentina ya se encuentra la ciudad de
Buenos Aires Inés Bienvenida al programa
Qué tal termina usted su semana allí en
la capital Argentina en donde parece que
el verano se prolonga más de lo esperado
exactamente Es un otoño muy veraniego el
nuestro Santiago Hola cómo estás y
esperemos que rápidamente calmen las
temperaturas porque sofocante lo que
estamos viviendo fue un verano intenso
allí en Argentina y también en los
países vecinos y también está con
nosotros en este programa Gonzalo lazari
él es editor internacional de Blu radio
una radio colombiana
Gonzalo qué tal termina usted su semana
bienvenido
Don Santiago Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación Bueno una semana ajetreada
interesante noticia que nos ha llegado
sobre todo de diferentes martes del
mundo pero aquí dentro de acompañarlo
para debatir sobre esos tópicos esos
titulares que fueron tendencias durante
estos cinco días no nos faltan los temas
lo que nos falta es tiempo para analizar
todo lo que ocurrió esta semana Gonzalo
y también en el estudio de Francia 24
está con nosotros Lorena Fadul ella es
periodista internacional Lorena
bienvenida aquí al estudio France 24 en
Bogotá qué tal termina usted su semana
Gracias Santiago una semana muy movida
Pero bueno ya estamos llegando al final
con muchas noticias y muchos
acontecimientos internacionales
importantes para destacar ustedes
también pueden acompañarnos con sus
opiniones y comentarios y también
preguntas por supuesto a través de las
redes sociales nos encuentran como
arroba
franz24_es santilogo arroba santilogo
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta es
numeral una semana en el mundo pues
comenzamos este recorrido enfocándonos
en esa visita de tres días del
presidente chino chilling pin a Rusia en
donde se reunió con su homólogo Vladimir
Putin los mandatarios se enfocaron en
las en los encuentros que tuvieron en el
kremlin en fortalecer las relaciones
comerciales y también en ese plan de 12
puntos que propuso China para Ucrania y
que el kremlin dijo que pues va a
estudiar meticulosamente no mostró mucho
entusiasmo por ese plan que estaba
presentando Beijing también ambos países
quieren fortalecer ese bloque a nivel
internacional que busca un mundo
multipolar sin la hegemonía de Estados
Unidos y un mundo multipolar más justo
vamos a comenzar entonces con Inés en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires preguntándole
Pues cuál es su opinión la sensación que
deja esta reunión y el fortalecimiento
de este eje Moscú Beijing
bueno Santiago básicamente lo que me
deja más que certezas de preguntas Esta
visita de shing King a Moscú porque
porque por un lado se puede ver la
visita como una muestra de respaldo
absoluto de China Rusia en su invasión a
Ucrania pero por el otro lado se puede
ver como el intento de mediación de una
potencia que también aspira a ser una
potencia global y tal vez la potencia
global hay señales de uno y otro lado
por lo tanto eso le quita peso
a la visita de como un respaldo absoluto
a Putin pero también le quita peso a su
intento de mediación además otro dato ya
para terminar no hubo propuestas
concretas de mediación eso por un lado
los doce puntos del plan de paz de China
son muy vagos y el otro y un dato
esencial es
simply quiere mediar también debería
hablar con el presidente de lensky de
Ucrania y eso hasta ahora no Esa fue la
conversación pendiente Inés después de
Esta visita de tres días al kremlin
Gonzalo sus impresiones su perspectiva
sobre Esta visita coincido con lo que
menciona Inés la primera visita del
presidente luego de la pandemia en este
caso vamos tú tenía ya cuatro años sin
visitar tierras rusas yo creo que aquí
lo que está haciendo sin es acercarse a
través de su socio más cercano valga la
redundancia en medio de esa guerra fría
que hay con los Estados Unidos y cae muy
bien por dos por dos aspectos uno por
las recientes relaciones abiertas que
tiene China con Ale Saudita en esa
cercanía con Irán y por otro lado por la
reelección justificado o no criticado No
es simpín a tener un tercer gobierno en
China Creo que ambos mandatarios estaban
buscando un respaldo de un lado y de
otro frente a lo que está sucediendo en
todo el planeta y aquí interesante que
un datico que se pudo conocer luego de
la conversación
o las conversaciones que tuvieron es que
nunca se habló de guerra nunca se habló
de Invasión del lado ruso le pidieron a
sillín Pink incluso a el gobierno de
China que no se tratara el tema del
conflicto bélico ni Ucrania como guerra
e invasión y así lo cumplió el gobierno
chino si uno hace un barrido por los
diferentes medios de comunicación de
China siempre se habla como la
terminología que ha dicho el kremlin una
operación militar especial o simplemente
un despliegue militar que tiene que
hacer Rusia en territorio ucraniano para
terminar esta primera ronda aquí en el
estudio de France 24 Lorena su
perspectiva este encuentro muy fuerte el
mensaje que se enviaba occidente de Esta
visita de estos dos presidentes pero
también Creo que es una respuesta a esas
constantes visitas que uno ve en kiev
que van primeros ministros europeos han
ido delegados de organismos
internacionales y también pues bueno
estuvo el presidente biden en kiev
también Sí yo creo que lo que hace
polémica Esta visita más que todo es que
china siempre mostró una posición
digamos que neutral frente al conflicto
entre Ucrania y Rusia y ahora llega a
traer estos puntos en el plan de paz que
lo que quieren más que todo es proponer
un ces al fuego de Rusia Ucrania pero
por ejemplo ahí no tocan el tema de
digamos retiro de tropas de Rusia y
tampoco como lo dijo mi colega tampoco
digamos que se puso en contacto con el
presidente de Ucrania Entonces ahí como
que deja como algunas dudas ese plan de
paz pues además de que china quiere como
tener esa imagen a nivel internacional
de gestor de paz por otro lado siento
que también el apoyo económico que le
está dando a Rusia
comprando el petróleo el gasto también
demuestra un poco de como apoyo en esta
situación y más que todo que esta visita
se da en un momento en el que hace pocos
días la Corte Penal Internacional
digamos que
emitió la orden de captura a Putin y
pues sale china digamos que a reforzar
ante el mundo la buena relación que
tiene con Rusia y digamos que está está
este apoyo que le está dando llena
Moscú a mí me deja una sensación que lo
podemos mirar como desde dos aristas No
sé ustedes cómo cómo lo ven Yo veo aquí
un poco que Rusia ha quedado atada a
China dependiente de ella en cierta
medida a nivel económico por la cantidad
de petróleo que le está comprando
también por la facilidad que le está
dando para acceder a ciertos préstamos a
través de bancos chinos Y pues seguir a
flote económicamente también queda un
poco atado a lo que china quiera mover
las fichas en el en el escenario
internacional pero también veo a China
mostrando justamente el presidente
chillepin y Esto va en línea con lo que
decía Gonzalo que como fue reelecto hace
pocas semanas Pues esta puede ser como
la forma de Mostrar cómo va a ser ese
nuevo mandato un poco más enfocado hacia
una china más abierta a nivel
internacional pero
mostrándose como un gestor de paz como
un país garante como que se ofrece a
mediar por lo menos desde el lado de sus
países aliados
hagamos la ronda la inversa Lorena qué
piensa usted no de acuerdo pienso que
digamos
Rusia está súper digamos que
comprometido económicamente con china
también porque al tener el rechazo de
los países occidentales pienso que china
entra a ser como un como un apoyo
económico muy grande para el país y
digamos que es como siento que Putin
también se siente respaldado en caso de
necesitar armas o necesitar seguridad
para el país Entonces ve a China como un
más que todo como un Aliado sí Inés en
la ciudad de Buenos Aires un Aliado
estratégico importante en la escena
internacional pero hasta qué punto china
se va a comprometer con Rusia
bueno es que ahí entran a jugar otros
aliados estratégicos de China sobre todo
de Europa si China si este viaje de lo
muestra demasiado cercano
a China de Europa y Cuál es la
importancia de Europa Bueno pues Europa
y Estados Unidos son los principales
socios comerciales hoy de China muy
necesarios para recuperar la economía
china que es probablemente el gran
sustento de este nuevo mandato Dean y
Gonzalo su opinión Que tanto se puede
involucrar china en este escenario
internacional habían evitado meterse a
hablar del tema de Ucrania ya solamente
llegar a proponer un plan de paz de 12
puntos pues ya muestra una posición un
poco más afín hacia una de las partes y
también un poco más involucrado el tema
de Santiago que para buscar la paz usted
necesita de dos partes y lo que ha dicho
el presidente de un plan es que a
nosotros bellísimos nos ha tocado la
puerta entonces es esa Paz de la se
habla que estaría imputado por china
cuan real puede ser a mí me genera mucho
su eficacia la posición porque puede ser
muy parecida la posición de erdogan en
donde uno no sabe en dónde o a qué lado
está jugando se acerca a Rusia luego se
acercó Ucrania algunas palabras pero no
hay ningún tema concreto Más allá de una
simple conversación que se puede dar en
territorio ruso en este caso ucraniano y
defendiendo los intereses porque eso es
lo que ha hecho Turquía a lo largo de
este año de guerra ha sido defender esa
posición estratégica que tiene el país y
defender los intereses que tiene el
presidente Turco en este escenario
Gonzalo continuó con usted y le pregunto
por esa esa figura de China ahora como
un gestor de paz no es el primer
escenario este escenario de Ucrania lo
vemos también hace unos días siendo
partícipe de ese de ese nuevo encuentro
de ese relanzamiento de las relaciones
entre Arabia Saudita e Irán países que
en el escenario de medio oriente era
impensable que volvieran a tener
acercamientos
a ver llama la atención Cuál va a ser la
posición que tenga Israel frente a esto
por qué Porque recordemos que Israel
está teniendo un nuevo proceso de paso
de relación con Oriente medio sobre todo
con Arabia Saudita Pero qué pasa Arabia
Saudita es muy cercano a Irán Y de
alguna u otra manera estos tres países
ya alineados pueden generar algún tipo
de duda frente a Israel y recordemos que
Israel no es que esté tan cercano al
gobierno de biden en este momento por el
tratado nuclear que se prevé en algún
momento firmar entre Irán y entre los
Estados Unidos yo creo que lo que está
haciendo china como usted bien lo
planteado Santiago es empezar a
mostrarse como esa potencia como ese ese
monstruo que sería dentro de algunos
años como el principal país a nivel de
importancia económica en todo el planeta
en esa opinión
Sí yo creo que las aspiraciones de China
están son bien transparentes Son
concretas son las aspiraciones de
competir con Estados Unidos en el en el
escenario diplomático con la misma
influencia que Estados Unidos en ese
sentido el acuerdo entre Arabia Saudita
y Irán fue un golazo para hablar en
términos de fútbol ahora
puede china replicar semejante éxito en
Ucrania lo que le daría verdaderamente
el estatus de potencia global tengo mis
enormes dudas primero porque son más las
señales de que es una potencia que apoya
a otra potencia beligerante por lo tanto
su su impacto mediador desciende y
segundo porque los la capacidad
diplomática para aplicar un plan de paz
No todavía no tienen ni experiencia ni
tampoco tanta influencia china en eso
entonces hay que ver verdaderamente Qué
tan lejos puede llegar además que en ese
escenario de una guerra en Ucrania de la
guerra en Ucrania ya lo de la palabra
Lorena
aquí claramente las dos partes van a
tener que ceder en algún punto al tienen
que dar algunas concesiones de Cara a
una posible paz en el futuro y qué tanto
a China le conviene una Rusia derrotada
pongámoslo entre comillas en el
escenario internacional cuando además
hay que Añadir que Rusia y china sí se
ayudan en muchos escenarios pero también
en otros escenarios Ellos están
compitiendo por presencia por intereses
comerciales intereses militares y
simplemente por ejercer
presencia caso Asia central caso África
por ejemplo para ir cerrando Lorena este
tema de de China y Rusia interesante que
qué mensaje le puede haber llegado a
occidente a raíz de este encuentro que
se le se le mandó directo a Bruselas y a
Washington yo lo que pienso es un Aliado
para China para Rusia Perdón
en un momento donde Putin está
vulnerable donde lo acaban de ordenar la
detención cuando ya todos muchos de los
países occidentales le están dando la
espalda y llega a China a reforzar esta
relación que tiene con Rusia y la verdad
es que pues Estados Unidos y los países
occidentales lo ven como más que todo
como una estrategia como un Aliado
también para este tema y piensan que tal
vez china pueda estar digamos que
dándole armas a Rusia para para este
conflicto que tiene con Ucrania esa es
una de las teorías del mundo occidental
lo que queda claro es que Rusia no está
sola en este conflicto y en estas
divisiones a nivel internacional
cerramos este capítulo vamos a seguir en
Europa vamos a hablar de Francia este
país está que arde los ciudadanos
franceses salieron ya varias veces a las
calles a lo largo de esta semana para
mostrar su rechazo por la aprobación por
decreto de la Reforma al sistema de
pensiones los sindicatos sectores
sociales diferentes sectores políticos
han rechazado esta decisión del
presidente Manuel de aprobar la
propuesta de reforma al sistema de
pensiones como ya les decía una reforma
que es necesaria para ser sostenible el
sistema en sí y que ha tenido un alto
costo político para el mandatario para
la otra semana ya están previstas
múltiples manifestaciones no solamente
en París sino en otras ciudades de el
país en otras ciudades francesas y
también en algunos territorios de
ultramar y los organizadores han dicho
que van a ser multitudinarias incluso
incendiarias comienzo con Gonzalo en
Ciudad de Panamá hay mucha presión sobre
el presidente en este momento y no de
abrazo a torcer y yo creo que esa
posición para algunos es aplaudible
Santiago el hecho de que macron no haya
cedido frente a las protestas y ese
aplaudible en el sentido de que macron
sabe que si esta reforma no pasa el
déficit que tendrá Francia que pagar por
el por por la misma por esa por esa
tirada a la basura por llamarlo así por
ese engavetamiento de la Reforma Será
muy alto macron está diciendo es Oigan
esto tenemos que pasarlo porque si no a
Francia le va a poder le va a costar
muchísimo La pregunta es tendrá la
capacidad macron de aguantar las
protestas a pesar de lo que le vaya a
costar a Francia no lo sabemos incluso
la semana pasada se estaba mencionando
que para los franceses el tema de la
jubilación es muy importante y el
aumento tan solo de dos años puede
generar lo que estamos viendo
cuánto político hay detrás de la
protesta es lo que llama la atención
algunos incluyo incluso señalan a la
izquierda más radical lo cierto del caso
es que yo sí tengo que aplaudir desde un
punto de vista muy personal la actitud
de un presidente que está diciendo si no
aprobamos esto esto nos va a salir muy
caro sí ha dicho que es una reforma
impopular pero es que son 12500 millones
de euros lo que le costaría al sistema
quedaría completamente desbalanceado
para el año 2030 Inés mucha presión y es
un escenario muy distinto
a lo que veíamos hace algunos años con
los chalecos amarillos en sus
manifestaciones de los sábados esto cada
vez está generando más descontento
dentro de la población dentro de los
franceses que no sé usted qué piensa
Inés Que aquí se está sumando no
solamente el descontento por esta
reforma sino por muchos otros factores
más
Sí por supuesto Santiago Francia viene
de varios años de movilización no solo
con los técnicos amarillos también antes
por qué porque hay una hay una reducción
de los niveles de vida una palabra o una
composición muy presente en todas las
campañas electorales francesas de la
última década fue poder adquisitivo
porque porque el poder adquisitivo cae
casi constantemente en Francia también
en el resto de los países de Europa A
eso se le agrega que los franceses van a
tener que trabajar dos años más
y aportar más para jubilarse y mantener
también ciertos niveles de vida Pos
retiro entonces eso hace que el nivel de
insatisfacción de Francia sea muy
patente lo que vemos en las calles la
manifestación es también parte de una
tradición de movilización de Francia
porque ojo el problema de la bomba
previsional lo tienen todos los países
del Mundo hoy por qué porque las
poblaciones empiezan a envejecer y no
hay recambios pero en Francia la
tradición de movilización es lo que hoy
pone en jaque la presidencia de macú
claro dos cosas ahí puntuales Pese a que
aumenten estos dos años para entrar en
el proceso de jubilación sigue siendo
por debajo del promedio de la Unión
Europea es decir Francia tiene unas
condiciones un poco más
amigables digámoslo así si se compara
con otros países incluso con países
fuera de la Unión Europea como Japón y
claro las marchas son habituales en
Francia los sindicatos son sumamente
fuertes y todas las manifestaciones no
es un país como Colombia en donde las
manifestaciones eran mal vistas hasta
hace algunos cuantos años cuando ya se
rompió todo ese mito y la gente pues
protesta se podía protestar libremente
pero era mal visto porque era de
comunistas de izquierda y guerrilleros
No ahora la sociedad sale y protesta
cuando lo tiene que hacer Lorena aquí en
el estudio de France 24 impresiones de
lo que pasa allí en Francia una olla a
presión comprimida yo lo que opino es
que es una población que ya viene
cansada como decía mi colega desde el
2018 y antes incluso con la movilización
de los chalecos amarillos que estaban
digamos que luchando por su poco poder
adquisitivo digamos que ellos ven el
alzan los precios ven que no les está
alcanzando el dinero por otro lado
después la pandemia pasó y pues a nivel
mundial fue una crisis económica muy
grande que también afectó a Francia por
el cierre de fronteras por el cierre
empresas despidos masivos etcétera
ahora la población ya está cansada
Digamos que ya están digamos no una
respuesta no en una solución a esto y
con esta reforma ven que en vez digamos
que de recibir un poco de apoyo lo que
ven es que el gobierno lo que está
haciendo es digamos que extendiéndole
esos años de trabajo y es un es un
futuro muy incierto para la población
porque ellos dicen bueno no hay trabajo
no nos está alcanzando el dinero la
inflación pues no está bien y digamos
que no ven que macron esté como
dispuesto a hablar o amediar con ellos
Entonces claro también siento que eso
hace que las protestas estén poniendo
más agresivas y que la gente Digamos que
ya esté digamos alzando mucho más la voz
no ha conversado con los sindicatos
hasta ahora el presidente macó Para ir
cerrando el tema Inés Qué puede venir
para Francia para las próximas semanas
Esto va a ser un punto de quiebre para
la presidencia de macó un punto de
quiebre para la Unión Europea y yo decía
ahorita que Francia parecía una olla
express Esto va a estallar como lo ve
usted
sí es un punto de quiebre para la
presidencia de más Cómo pero yo creo que
la propia tradición de movilización de
Francia va a ser que no sea un punto de
quiebre para Francia es decir va a
crecer la atención las calles van a
seguir incendiadas Pero eso no va a
representar digamos llevar al extremo a
la presidencia de más cuando yo creo que
se va a sostener la reforma y que maco
hacia fin de año que él llame su
gobierno sabe que tiene que sostenerse
hasta fin de año hacia fin de año va a
lograr empezar a navegar con más
tranquilidad las aguas de la sociedad
francesa Gonzalo su opinión como puede
bajar Entonces el agua está de acuerdo
Usted con Inés Completamente de acuerdo
con Inés yo creo que grave problema que
ha tenido Más allá de felicitarlo por
aguantar las protestas frente a lo que
sería una hecatombe económica es tratar
de convencer al pueblo francés creo que
el grave error que ha tenido macron Es
la falta de comunicación de un frente a
lo que le va a costar a Francia si
reforma no se aprueba y lo usted decía
algo muy importante Santiago y para
poner en contexto de los oyentes en
países como Italia como Estonia como
Países Bajos como Alemania como Irlanda
la gente se jubila mucho más anciana por
llamarlo así o de edad mucho más adulta
eh que en Francia y yo creo que ahí
coincidiendo con Inés lo que tendría que
mejorar macron es el poder de
convencimiento la comunicación frente a
los franceses de que esta reforma es
necesaria para cuidar las arcas del país
claro esto a futuro puede salirle más
caro al gobierno que esté de turno más
adelante ustedes mencionan la
comunicación Lorena no sé si usted
coincide es muy raro ver al presidente
Mako teniendo problemas de comunicación
con los ciudadanos cuando ha sido un
excelente comunicador tiene la facilidad
de conectarse con la gente y una de las
cosas que destacaban de sus campañas
cuando llegó por primera vez a la
presidencia fue justamente la forma como
se comunicaba con la gente la estrategia
de comunicación fue admirable Pues ahora
parece que que esto no le está
funcionando y no convence a los
franceses algún otro comentario para
hacer sobre el tema Francia o lo
cerramos acá Lorena lo cerramos acá
avanzamos entonces con otro tema de la
agenda y eso nos lleva hasta África
continente del que tenemos noticias
Pues que en América Latina poco
comentamos pero esta semana captó la
atención de la comunidad internacional
esa decisión que fue tomada por el
parlamento ugandés el proyecto de ley
que busca castigar con hasta diez años
de prisión a quienes se identifiquen
como integrantes del colectivo lgbti más
Además de eso cerca de 500 diputados
ugandeses acordaron también introducir
la pena de muerte por delitos de
homosexualidad agravada un proyecto que
está todavía en estudio por el
parlamento de este país africano la ONU
amnistía internacional Estados Unidos
otros países africanos incluso países
también de la Unión Europea pues han
criticado esta medida ya sabemos con
anterioridad equivocando es un país en
donde las leyes contra este tipo de
minorías son bastante
complejas y rígidas Pero esto ya abre
otro tipo de
escenario y por eso lo traemos aquí para
el debate y la discusión Comencemos
entonces con Lorena aquí su opinión
sobre esta medida Bueno yo opino que
jugando con esta medida lo que está
haciendo es tener un retroceso gigante
ya que viendo el contexto internacional
y pues a nivel mundial todos los países
lo que están haciendo es justamente
tratar de apoyar la libertad la libre
expresión tratar de sacar leyes donde se
apruebe el matrimonio gay donde se pueda
adoptar de pronto el matrimonios gays y
uganda lo que está haciendo es
retroceder o digamos que echar para
atrás todo esto que está trabajando se
está trabajando a nivel internacional y
lo que está creando es primero Pues
estaba violando los derechos humanos y
segundo está creando un odio y una
discriminación en su sociedad que en un
futuro pues no sabemos hasta dónde va a
llegar ya que las mismas personas entre
familias van a tener que denunciar a
personas homosexuales o van a tener que
digamos que
aguantar como todos estos ataques que
van a empezar a ver contra la población
del lgtbi Entonces no sé hasta dónde
pueda llegar esto pasó a darle la
palabra Inés en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires Inés es una medida la está
probando el parlamento ugandés como lo
indica la Constitución de este país pero
aquí estamos siendo viendo esta medida
desde un mundo muy occidental no tal vez
nos cuesta un poco entender cuál es la
realidad africana
si es probable eso pero también es
cierto Santiago que uganda siempre fue
muy estricto acá y muy reaccionario
también retardatario en cuanto a la
libertad sexual en respecto incluso de
sus vecinos cercanos Wanda etcétera
es porque lo asemeja más a una teocracia
que a un país que pretende ser una
democracia una democracia con los visos
propios de esa región pero democracia al
fin mu Seven y el presidente musebén y
que gobiernan ya hace varias décadas
nunca ocultoso disgusto ante las
tendencias de lgbt entonces a mí
realmente no me sorprende sí lo que me
sorprende es que todos los órganos del
Estado El poder legislativo el poder
judicial se hayan sumado a esta ofensiva
tan retardataria que atrasa tanto cuando
eso va a exponer a uganda a un montón de
sanciones y en un país que se aprecia de
ser abierto y de dialogar con sus
vecinos y con el resto del mundo eso
puede ser bastante riesgoso le puede
tener bastantes costos al presidente
museo sí por la por lo pronto ha habido
algunas críticas pero todavía no hay
condenas a nivel internacional a uganda
Hay que decir también Gonzalo que es que
África pues es un continente muy
particular son naciones muy jóvenes con
sociedades con unas particularidades que
no podemos verlas con la misma lupa que
vemos una sociedad en Europa o incluso
en América Latina viéndolo así solamente
Sudáfrica sería como el país más
parecido a a tener leyes similares a las
que hay de este lado del mundo es su
opinión sobre este tema
Bueno es un retroceso sin duda alguna a
la evolución de los Derechos Humanos en
el planeta tierra Porque uganda entra
ahora esa fatídicalista de al menos once
países en donde se condena con pena de
muerte la homosexualidad en países como
árabes Saudita como yemen como Irán
incluso algunas zonas de Nigeria la la
homosexualidad de esta castigada con la
pena de muerte aquí lo interesante es
que hay un tema religioso cuando uno
escucha en las palabras de algunos
miembros de la asamblea o del senado
grandés defendiendo el por qué Sí esta
ley salen a hablar y a relucir el tema
eclesiástico en Cómo la homosexualidad y
según palabras el Ministerio de obras
públicas de uganda está amenazando a la
raza humana está amenazando las mujeres
a los hombres entonces también Aquí hay
una connotación digamos religiosa al
menos dentro del argumento que
plantearon en su momento Durante esa ese
debate de cinco horas algunos miembros
del senado grandeza
Inés usted hablaba de de sanciones a
nivel internacional que puede venir
Entonces para onda En este sentido Qué
condenas puede empezar a ver
la Unión Europea y y Estados Unidos que
son digamos el bloque y el país que más
condiciona sus relaciones sobre todo
institucionales a la libertad y la
Libertad en todo sentido la libertad
sexual la libertad religiosa la libertad
de expresión por lo tanto es de esperar
que ahí sí haya algún tipo de sanciones
no así Dentro del resto de la unión
africana los vecinos de uganda Lorena
para el cierre sobre este tema se lo
estaba mencionando para la primera
intervención sobre este tema y es al
mundo occidental en general partiendo
como ejemplo este tema de uganda pero
nos cuesta un poco entender otro tipo de
culturas otro tipo de realidades otro
tipo de de contextos en los que se
mueven las sociedades y criticamos
calificamos desde nuestro punto de vista
occidental pretendiendo que por ejemplo
una sociedad como la iraní o la de
Arabia Saudita o yemen o de las islas
del Pacífico se muevan al ritmo de la
comunidad internacional de occidente
Pues en realidad yo siento que sí tal
vez a veces es un poco difícil para
nosotros pues para la comunidad
internacional y entender los diferentes
motivos por los cuales este país está
Tomando estas medidas pero con lo que de
pronto no estoy de acuerdo es con esos
castigos que se le están dando a la
población lgtbi ya que son castigos que
en realidad están violando con los
derechos humanos y que puede que ellos
no acepten a la gente del lgtbi Pero
puede que no O sea no no deberían tener
estos castigos tan fuertes hacia ellos y
siento que deberían pensar de pronto en
otra manera de o sea de respetar su
religión sus culturas todo pero sin
violar como estos derechos humanos
fundamentales para para la población en
cualquier contexto en el que esté
cerramos ahí nuestros temas fuertes de
la semana se nos quedan por fuera
muchísimos Por supuesto que sí el mundo
no paró y no para a lo largo de estos
cinco días sucedieron cualquier cantidad
de cosas vamos ahora a nuestro
comentario de la semana Este es un
espacio dentro del programa en el que
ponemos un tema sobre la mesa y nuestros
invitados Pues hacen un breve comentario
sobre lo que piensan o su posición o el
análisis que pueden hacer sobre este
tema
destacado también a lo largo de la
semana Entonces ese extenso debate que
hay sobre la red social tiktok que es
una de las redes más exitosas no
obstante hay una polémica grande a nivel
internacional porque ha sido restringida
prohibida en algunos países Estados
Unidos es prácticamente el país que está
liderando esta Cruzada no es que se haya
puesto la camiseta pero las medidas que
ha ido adoptando y los debates que se
han dado en Estados Unidos han servido
de ejemplo o de idea para otros países
para seguirle El Paso Les pedimos
entonces a nuestros invitados que
piensan sobre sobre este debate que hay
en torno a tiktok y comienzo con Lorena
aquí en el estudio de France 24 tiene
usted cuenta en tiktok Sí claro claro
creo que hoy muchos tenemos cuenta en
tiktok lo usamos como medio de
comunicación como medio de como redes
Social para expresar diferentes tipos de
de opiniones o simplemente para
divertirnos sin embargo pienso que la
posición de Estados Unidos frente a la
aplicación tiktok y frente a lo que
estaba comentando el sí o de tiktok
sobre esto siento que es una una
posición un poco apresurada Estados
Unidos piensa que tal vez la Data o pues
la información que tiene tiktok la van a
usar en su contra o digamos que es un
como un Aliado con china pero pienso que
hasta el momento no se tienen pruebas de
eso hasta el momento siento que no
tienen por qué digamos presionar a
cerrar la aplicación cuando aún todavía
pues no no tienen como nada asegurado y
tal vez esto pueda como interferir un
poco como con el Libre Mercado Inés su
comentario
un poco de Lorena
lo que Estados Unidos dice y que el sí o
no pudo hacer explicar entre el congreso
norteamericano es Qué sucede con todas
las los datos la identificación personal
de los 150 millones de usuarios que
tiene tiktok solo en Estados Unidos qué
sucede con eso Para qué se usa dónde se
almacena nada de eso pudo ser respondido
de por el el chino de tiktok por lo
tanto ahí Abre una un enorme duda Pero
de fondo creo que tiktok es hoy la
manifestación de lo que va a hacer en el
futuro esta competencia que va a
terminar siendo una gran rivalidad entre
Estados Unidos y China y cómo va a
afectar en la vida diaria al resto del
mundo tiene muchos tintes políticos está
esta discusión Gonzalo su comentario
sobre el tema de tiktok
coincido es una guerra política
justamente en el año 2020 el Washington
post hizo una investigación en la que se
confirmó que tiktok no recoge más datos
que lo que otras redes sociales recogen
por ejemplo Instagram o Twitter Aquí es
importante lo que menciona Inés dónde se
almacenan esos datos se almacenan en
Estados Unidos O se almacenan en China y
ahí está el gran debate la pregunta que
se hace hoy en día es debe Estados
Unidos tomar la misma actitud que tiene
China con respecto a otras grandes
tecnológicas por ejemplo Google o
WhatsApp sí porque lo digo porque en
China usted no puede utilizar WhatsApp
utiliza WhatsApp usted no puede utilizar
Google porque está controlado por el
gobierno chino La pregunta es albanear
al vetar por completo el uso de tics en
los ciudadanos Estados Unidos se
comportaría como China
queda ahí la pregunta pueden comentarlo
a través de las redes sociales de una
semana en el mundo y de France 24 yo en
lo personal no tengo cuenta de tiktok
con Instagram y Twitter Me basta me
queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa les pregunto a los tres
invitados Qué temas van a tener ustedes
bajo la lupa en el ojo para la próxima
semana Gonzalo comienzo con usted en
Ciudad de Panamá
Yo tengo un tema que es muy importante
la decisión que se vaya a tomar en el
senado con respecto a la aprobación o no
lo que comentábamos hace minutos de la
Reforma pensional en Francia sí Inés en
la ciudad de Buenos Aires sus temas Mira
el tema de la Argentina que es un tema
global es el tema de cómo la sequía está
afectando la economía Argentina
probablemente lleva la Argentina a un
límite que aún no conocemos y eso tiene
que ver con un tema que este fin de
semana se va a tratar en República
Dominicana y es el cambio climático Y
cómo nos está impactando cómo nos está
modificando hoy ya segunda segundo la
vida y los gobiernos parecen no darse
cuenta en República Dominicana en el
contexto de la Cumbre iberoamericana
donde participan los países de nuestro
continente más España Portugal y andorra
y para el cierre Lorena Qué temas le van
a interesar a usted le van a poner van a
captar su atención a lo largo de la
semana con mis colegas especialmente
creo que todos vamos a estar muy atentos
al resultado o Pues a qué se va a estar
hablando en la Cumbre iberoamericana
oficialmente frente al cambio climático
que creo que es uno de los temas
principales de este de este año Bueno
también importante a lo largo de la
semana las conclusiones que pueda dejar
esa Cumbre iberoamericana que puede
tener repercusiones a lo largo de los
próximos días también lo que suceda en
países como por ejemplo Venezuela en el
marco De esa campaña anticorrupción que
genera mucha controversia en Venezuela
también decisiones que pueden haber en
Colombia y por supuesto que no podemos
perder de nuestro radar lo que suceda en
Ucrania a lo largo de la semana porque
sigue también la batalla por bahamut y
por otros sectores del este en la región
de el don vast pues es todo por esta
semana a Inés a Gonzalo y a Lorena aquí
en el estudio les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros Muchísimas gracias
por compartir con la audiencia de France
24 sus perspectivas y sus opiniones
sobre los temas que teníamos para el día
de hoy la producción del programa estuvo
a cargo de Laura garzón y Luis Fernando
Montes y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera ustedes
pueden seguir dejando los comentarios
preguntas que quieran hacer A través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]